all right so to all of you who are like
dude where's your review of Batman
Arkham City I gotta beat the game first
how crazy do you think I am
however now that I've eaten it here you
go Batman Arkham City
all right the reports are coming in
Batman Arkham City is getting like 99.5
ten out of ten it's crazy everyone loves
the game so how is it Batman Arkham City
is better than Batman Arkham Asylum I
didn't know how it could be but it is so
when Batman Arkham City a part of Gotham
City's been sectioned off and isolated
to form Arkham City you know a part of a
city has been sectioned off as a prison
kind of like Escape from New York with
the Batman how is that not awesome so
after one of the coolest intros that I
personally didn't expect now you're
Batman you're in Arkham City and you're
taking out all the criminals and what I
really liked about Batman Arkham City is
these criminals have sectioned off parts
of the city is like their territory and
not every criminal likes every criminal
so sometimes you got to form these
uneasy alliances with people by people I
mean you know bad guys that you know to
take out the other guys that's awesome
and you have the tech that you have from
the first game and you get a bunch of
new tech in this one you have like
double the items and just like Batman
Arkham Asylum you upgrade abilities you
upgrade moves you upgrade your tech a
little word of advice I'm just gonna let
you know this there are these little
side challenges like the waynetech
challenges where you have to glide with
your bat cape do the first five of those
you'll get an ability is one of the most
useful abilities you're going to get in
the game just in terms of story and
gameplay Batman Arkham Asylum seems so
small compared to Batman Arkham City
Batman Arkham City is definitive Batman
in every way shape and form
when you first start out the game you
start out and you can go anywhere in
Arkham City that just seems big and
heavy that's what she said then you
start getting the lay of the land you're
like alright now I'm the Batman I'm
taking deeds out and then you'll run
across like a Riddler trophy or
something like that and that leads to
another riddle which leads to another
riddle then you'll come across a ringing
phone that'll lead to another series of
side quests there's just so much to do
in this game the scope of the game is so
big and they didn't waste it at all they
filled it with a bunch of side missions
to do a bunch of Secrets a bunch of
quests that's how a game should feel
especially a game involving the Batman
and again Kevin Conroy voices Batman and
he is the Batman he'll hold up a thug
interrogate him and be like lie to me if
you're done chewing solid food and
you're just like and yeah if you were
sad that there was a villain that wasn't
featured in the first game odds are he
is in this game unless you're hoping for
like the clock king from Batman the
Animated Series they're probably in this
game and there's something about having
that new ability to dive-bomb when
you're
flying I mean you're gliding with your
back Cape just like the first one you
know how it is but now you're like
building height you know you're really
high and you can just fold in your cape
and just drop down you're like this is
so awesome I could do this for days the
funny part is it's absurd the reaches
back claw has in this game in the first
game it clearly was like okay I'm too
far away from that ledge I gotta get
closer
this was dude you can shoot like a city
block it's crazy I love it and yeah you
play as Catwoman in some of the missions
and what I really liked is that Catwoman
doesn't feel like a Batman mold with a
different body and that's it she doesn't
play like Batman she plays more like
Spider Man actually she can crawl up
buildings with her claws she whips onto
ledges and pulls herself up I liked
playing her missions too she is a bit
more limited she doesn't have all the
tech the Batman has here like I'm
clearly more limited but you don't feel
like you know nerf Batman or anything
like that it's Catwoman she's her own
person I only have a couple of gripes
with the game one of them is I remember
in Batman Arkham Asylum doing the ground
take down and knocking a guy out while
he's on the ground I remember it being
easier in that game in this game if you
do the ground takedown to a guy and
there's another guy who's mobile across
the room he will run over just to screw
that move up there douchebags I guess
that's not a big deal it's just we got
annoying after a while
and I'm nitpicking at this point but I
thought of this there were a couple
parts where Batman had to make a really
tough call as to what he had to do you
know prioritizing and whatnot I think it
would have been really cool if the game
let you choose what to do you know like
a Bioware game or something that would
have been awesome it's not like I walked
away from the game going you know what
it would have been a great game but it
didn't let me choose on those couple
parts you know like a bio art game it's
not a bio art game and I didn't expect
to be able to choose but then when it
came up and it looks like I could have
chosen and it didn't let me uh uh you
know I'm not gonna be like that I like
the game's less cool just saying and
those are my only real gripes about the
game other than that the game is so
solid and I'll admit it I haven't maxed
the game out a hundred percent I beat
the game I got a number of the secrets I
haven't gotten all the secrets so I got
to go back up and I got to finish off
the secrets it's fine if you beat the
game and don't get all the secrets
because you know now you're Batman you
can do free roaming after you beat the
game you can just round up all the
riddles and secrets and stuff like that
however I wanted to get this review to
you before the holidays before Christmas
I figured if I got all the secrets you
know I wouldn't be able to it's a big
game dude so I got to go back and get
all the secrets and spend more hours
after I beat in the game and the cool
thing is I'm excited to do that it's not
one of those games after you beat the
game you're like alright whatever I can
just put it down now and that's that I
have not yet heard anyone who's bought
this game say something like I paid 60
bucks for this game and I really don't
think I ever will
I would say Batman Arkham City I'm gonna
go for it is awesome tacular Batman
Arkham City is a definitive Batman story
if ever there was one so Batman stories
what's your favorite Batman story for
all you Batman fanatics out there I mean
even an episode of Batman the Animated
Series whatever go for it if you say
Batman and Robin God will kill a kitten
in any case comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more